جبل من الركان انها انقاض مدينه كهرمان
مرش في مكان قريب منها تتخذ المدينه شكلا
اخر
عائلات فقدت بيوتها بدات تنتقل للمدينه
الصغيره قيد الانشاء مدينه بمنازل جاهزه
ستستضيف اكثر من الف عائله
فقدنا افرادا من العائله فقدنا احبائنا
عنان الكثير كان الامر صعبا في البدايه
وبقينا في السيارات الان اتينا الى هنا
كان لدينا منزل تدمر بالكامل في الزلزال
ان تشلنا من تحت الانقاض سالمين احمد الله
على هذا المنزل الان
اسبوعان من راى على الفاجعه وفرق العمل
هنا تسابق الزمن في مكان مفتوح على اطراف
المدينه تحضر منظمه افاد وحدات سكنيه
مجهزه باحتياجات الحياه اليوميه
لم ينتهي العمل بالكامل فالنموذج هذا
سيطبق في باقي المدن المنكوبه
هدفنا بناء قرابه 100 الف منزل جاهز في
المدن المنكوبه خلال شهرين جهزنا نحو 6000
في منزل حتى الان وبالفعل انجز العمل على
البنيه التحتيه لنحو ثمانيه وستين الف
منزل جاهز
قدرت السلطات الرسميه عدد المباني
المتضرره بشده او المنهاره بنحو 120 الفا
والى حين انطلاق اولى مراحل اعاده الاعمار
بدايه الشهر المقبل ستكون المنازل الجاهزه
مستقرا للمنكوبين من مركز الزلزال في
كهرمان مراش اذا انطلقت المرحله الثانيه
لاسكان العائلات المتضرره لن تكون هذه
بديلا عن منازلهم بالطبع لكنها محطه على
طريق التعافي الطويل سلام خضر الجزيره
كهرماش